the final season part two I was kind of
bored I I I and attack on time just
fumbled the bag at the end in my opinion
to the point where like I can't take
this [__] seriously anymore these naming
conventions are garbage this is not a
take I'm here right
now hello and welcome to another episode
of trash taste I'm your host for today G
and joining me once again are the boys
and uh what can I say the biggest piece
of anime like the biggest event in anime
has just dropped guys the biggest piece
of anime the biggest piece of anime
definit definitely the anime of all time
definitely in the history of anime
bigger than Dragon Ball bigger than one
piece bigger than the Bible two do you
want do you want to reiterate for people
who perhaps don't know what the
thumbnail is they've been living under a
rock yeah so uh Attack on Titan just
finished airing this week so we thought
we'd do our topal episode because uh
we've all seen Attack on Titan right
right right surely I finished it I
finished it I finished it did you
actually yeah I finished it oh okay why
you why are you looking at it like [__]
I thought you on my side I watch I
watched it oh okay I didn't
why okay you had you had one job we with
take one J I just don't care about
Attack on Titan anymore okay that's just
like okay it might be because like how
far did you get I got up to the oh God
the naming convention uh the final
season part one okay wait is that the
correct ter I don't even know what the
[__] doesn't the final season have three
parts final season there three parts
there in the third part there's two
parts oh yeah okay so that means I got
up to yeah part two I haven't watched
the I haven't watched the third season
part one or two just the the two hour
long the 2our long ones yeah I got up to
there so you you basically just got
everything up to the ending bit yeah so
you've only got like 2 and a half hours
of Attack on Titan left to go and you
don't have any interest in finishing it
I'll get to it eventually I guess but
I'm not in a rush all right so I I'm
going to say like normally we have like
a spoiler warning or something but we
you know uh normally sorry normally we
try to avoid spoilers but I'm pretty
sure we can't discuss all of this
without spoiling are we discussing it I
haven't even seen it yeah if we if we do
spoilers people are going to skip right
in the start of the episode so we we'll
save a little bit of the spoilers for
lat singing The Meta game yeah cuz if
we's going to YouTube's going to hate
this episode if we do that yeah don't
worry we'll give you guys a warning when
we get when we actually get to the
ending but yeah I feel like I watched it
I did watch the ending just out of like
commitment I'm like well I'm like I'm
this far in I should just finish it well
I mean what it was a 10year run right
yeah I've been watching it since it came
out so 2013 it like it really was this
it really is like an end of an era cuz I
think Attack on Titan really kind of
grew up with the medium it was kind of
like that first big push of like oh
anime has like gone from this little
niche thing to something that can kind
of like meet mainstream culture and it
was kind of like it it kind of to me as
Howen Titan signified that show from
anime growing from something that was a
bit more Niche to something that now is
even like arguably mainstream you know
tot I think it's very men and even
people who don't like anime are like I
know teken Titan yeah yeah exactly I
remember cuz I I think I got into anime
in like 2012 2011 and then Attack on
Titan was the one that was really big
yeah and before that I actually didn't
watch Subs I was like no I'm a dub only
guy I don't want to read [__] but attack
Titan uh didn't have a dub for a very
long time and I was like well [__] I got
to I got to watch and when the dub came
out it was an amazing
dub uh I think the dub is actually
pretty good I think the dub the dub I've
I've I've watched both the sub and the
dub uh and the dub was actually for the
most part pretty damn good uh I me when
I think of the dub I think of the Arman
scream yeah well that that was kind of
iconic iconic I don't remember this one
you don't remember it a big meme it was
a huge meme of the dub Arman scream of
like I think it was like episode two or
three of season one when like the first
big like I guess uh twist happens right
with Aaron um and Armen does this scream
and in the Japanese one it's very
powerful and then the dub came out and
it got Meed to absolute [__] pull it up
pull it up okay I got to hear this I'm
surprised you haven't seen this just
almond scream dub just almond scream dub
almond scream dub I mean like while
while we're pulling this up um yeah I
mean I've watched all of the dub except
for the final season of the D okay yeah
yeah yeah oh you watched a lot of it
I've rewatched Al Titan quite quite a
few times well it's uh is it Matthew
Mercy plays Levi uh I can't remember I
mean it makes sense I feel like it is I
feel I'm if it's not him go go go to the
end go to the end just the scream yeah
yeah yeah right there yeah right there
so it's this
part that scream was the
meme
okay it sounds like a very Crush
bandic
nature I don't think it was necessarily
bad it was just like it's very funny out
of context yeah yeah yeah I'm also
biased I I think cuz Michael Tatum is uh
he's wiwin I think he crushes it now no
I think win I think I think Irwin was
actually my favorite performance from
the dub uh Irwin completely I didn't
know it was J marum makes a lot of sense
I think my biggest problem with the dub
where I would recommend the sub over the
dub U was unfortunately B Bryce papen
Brook's uh portrayal of Aaron uh because
I think he does really good in season
one but there are some kind of like
moments uh a lot as the series goes on
yeah yeah there there was some moments
where I think I think he's like a really
talented voice actor but I think he got
casted at a time where he was getting
casted as every K yeah he was K as like
every edgy kind of like protagonist yeah
he get um and so I I I think you know he
does really really good in other roles
and there was like a certain few moments
where I just didn't think he hit the
same like emotional beats as other
people could have done if they had G
been casted as Aaron I think the scene
that really sold it for me was um eron's
breakdown in the end of season 2 where I
remember watching it and I was just like
ooh this is this is not hitting that
same emotional beat that the original
voice actor did who's the original voice
actor again Kaji Yuki did I mean kaj
Yuki's go a God kajuk is a God but uh
yeah it was uh it was something that I
didn't think matched up to the original
and um it was also a bit weird seeing I
saw a little bit of the beginning of
season 4 or like the final season and he
still had a very similar voice and I
heard he's improved that for like later
parts of the final season but it just it
just felt very off cuz uh uh so I would
actually genuinely I've watched both and
I would genuinely recommend the sub over
the dub this isn't like a stay against
the DU is bad say say the dub was bad
sure yeah but then if you if for some
reason youever say like I prefer the D
it people would be like a just can't
appreciate the
Japanese you're wee enough what you
talking about like hey I I'm fluent in
this language and I think it sounds good
in this language sometimes like happy to
admit when it sounds it's personal
preference at the end of the day there's
no right or wrong yeah I mean I I would
say Owen uh I didn't know it was J marel
Tatum but I actually prefer just
slightly just slightly because both are
like such goated performances but holy
[__] hearing his speech uh in English I
was like God this this hit different man
I'm ready to go to war right
now yeah I mean I'm biased Michael's
such a great actor in general so it's I
mean I I just like being around him
because he's always the way he talks
about acting is like man I wish wish my
brain just worked like this about acting
like there's just such a passion for it
well he's our boy you know like we're
going to be biased towards our boys yeah
anyway uh but I remember the dub didn't
come out for ages so I got into the sub
because I wanted to watch it and
everyone was talking about it and it was
uh I the dude the fandom back then was
so interesting for Attack on Titan uh is
it all interesting now but it was well
it is but it was just so like it was so
bizarre how uh it was at a time where I
felt that uh back then in the English
fandom I feel like manga readers were
like a huge minority oh yeah oh for sure
no one Read Manga much and and when you
interact with people they'd only ever it
just a given that you were like oh you
just you watched on the anime I I seldom
met people who had read the Manga
remember very very small vocal
Amed constantly being like the manger is
better the manger is better I was in a
bunch of like fan stuff when I was way
younger but like of people I guess doing
their own audio Productions of their own
madeup stories in the universe and I was
like
okay [__] it uh so I did like that but
uh yeah uh t on Titan otherwise uh I
said this earlier and this is why you
wanted to talk about it cuz you got
annoyed by my comments I felt like uh
although I I I wanted to finish this
journey because I felt like it it' kind
of been my entire adult life was Attack
on Titan I was like I should I should I
should watch it uh the final season part
two I was kind of
bored I I
I I can't
believe I I can't I like genuinely
genuinely all agree that the the
nomenclature I've been want to use that
word for so long of the the nomenclature
of the the attack on Titan series what
does that mean well god wow some go on
go on
intellectual the the the groups the
naming uh like how you name a certain
group of things and no man as in name
yeah okay and the way they've named the
series [__] awful absolutely the
worst naming job in history of show I
think that was my problem with
especially the final season is that I
the naming convention is just so
confusing away from the series yeah I
think it has as well to be honest and I
think that's why I just kind of lost
interest cuz I'm like they're not
[__] taking serious this is not a
take I'm here right now this is not this
is not there is no bearing on the show
can I just say this in general it is
absolutely [__] confusing to try and
keep track on on certain places to watch
this where you're like wait which
[__] one am I on again why do they
all have different you know it's bad
when like my Photoshop files named
better you know like the Xbox series 1 x
looks like a better naming system as
opposed to the [__] this is my message
to fate fans that say I over complicate
this [__] if these guys can't follow
along with conventions in attack on
titon [__] this is the exact same
reason is the exact same reason why a
lot of people struggle to get into fate
as well because they look at a title and
they go I don't know where this is
canonically speaking so I'm not even
going to bother starting to do it yeah I
mean this tag on time just fumbled the
bag at the end in my opinion to the
point where like I can't take this [__]
seriously anymore these naming
conventions are garbage that has no
[__] bearing on the has no bearing on
the show but personally I was like sh is
annoying as [__] it's annoying as [__]
there's nothing to do like this is like
the you know I thought you were coming
out with the big guns I will I will but
we just we have to recognize that they
[__] up with naming this show for some
goddamn reason you could be the biggest
Attack on Titan fan and every attack
time fan will agree the naming
convention is ass horrendous it's not
optimized but let's talk to like Kingdom
Hearts fans for like a second here and
just Reas another reason why people
don't take that [__] seriously because
they look at these Nami conventions and
they same with [__] monari any any
series that has the most like nonsecular
and non you know sequential naming
system people from the outside look at
it and go what the [__] is this how am I
supposed to get into I will say seeing
that name system slowly being revealed
and rolled out it did make me kind of
like lose confidence a bit in the
production I'm like I'm like how are you
guys fumbling this so badly like like
there is no goddamn reason why there
should be final season part one part two
part three that is that is insane like
what what like what actually happened
for this [__] there has to be a [__]
Look up the word final in the has to
have been a [__] up in a way that makes
me like that made me nervous initially
when it was coming out yeah because I
was like what is happening behind theen
you know like I'm I'm I'm going to
defend it for now uh because I believe
that this is this is all based on my
pure feeling and speculation and kind of
like the vibe I get now being you know
you know having talk to a lot of anime
Studios and stuff like that I'm sure
same with you Joey which is I'm sure
they had a rough schedule to begin with
when when like mappa got signed on and
then they were like wait a minute we
actually want to take time to make this
[__] slap so the reason I think this
is because you look at the difference in
quality from Attack on Titan uh final
season part one to everything that came
out of came after it like there is a
such a huge jump in animation quality
it's like not even comparable know and I
think that came came about because mappa
were like let's uh slow things down and
uh let's actually take time to make the
finale something that is worthy of the
lineage of Attack on Titan and you know
what if we get a bit of name [__] we
can meme about it all right but like
considering the final product we got I
think it was more than [__] worth the
wait you know I I see I would have been
happy to wait even longer as long as we
all just got it in one cleanly wrapped
packaging like I I feel like the fact
that they released these final seasons
in so many different parts just goes to
show that like well okay but you could
have instead of just releasing it you
know and splitting it up into 15
different [__] parts and confusing
everybody why couldn't you have just
pushed everything back and just given it
to us all in one go we're okay with
waiting for you guys to you know work
your magic with the animation and the
production everything that's fine we've
already we've already been waiting seven
eight years at this point right for it a
finish so it's like why couldn't they
have just pushed that all back to the
point where okay here we go here is the
final season allinone nicely need you
know wrapped up bag I agree and here you
go we also have recognized in the past
that for example Netflix kind of killed
little hype of Jojo the way that they
released it so you know the way you
release a series does matter as much as
much as like it shouldn't have any
bearing on the show you know a large
part about consuming media is the
surrounding hype are you into that are
you like following along with people
like that that that matters a lot to
just consuming media in general agree um
and I I think that it it you know it did
it did kind of detract a little bit from
from the series in a slight way nothing
meaningful of course but it did make it
did add an extra step where I felt that
like I felt like online generally people
just cared less about the show I
definitely agree um I think I don't know
what the creative decision between doing
the last finale in like two Mega hour an
hour and a half long episodes I they had
there's enough material there for a
season you know there's maybe not like a
full core 12 episode but definitely like
a strong 10 n episode like season I am
really shocked that that the final two
parts weren't just a movie genuinely I I
kind of did I not call this years ago I
think we all had a feeling that they
might try it I was like they're going to
end it with like movie length episodes
and especially with I was them being
essentially one pretty long movie I'm
kind of surprised they didn't try and
release it theatrically yeah they you'd
think they'd look at you know s like
Demon Slayer and take that as a hint
right it was like the worst parts of
Both Worlds you know you didn't get the
hype of releasing as like a full 9
episode season for like the hype to
build up but you also didn't get the
hype of having it be a theatrical
release which after you cut it in half
yeah and separated it over the course of
a year after watching it this could
definitely with like the with the
quality they had that they had this
could have definitely been a movie you
know um and they there are some like
moments love to watch this in the theat
oh it would have been incredible this is
the one time when I'm like yeah end it
with the movie you CLE you clearly want
to end it off with the bang if you don't
want to split up into like episodics uh
like a final third season um so just put
it as a movie but for some reason they
release there two long episodes that
just dropped at random intervals in the
year and I'm like that you you are doing
everything you can to like
kill and that's exactly what it did for
me it killed the hype for me where where
I got to the point where I'm just like
I'll get to it eventually I guess but
I'm not like frothing at the mouth to
finish it at the same time you want to
finish it I do well yeah because
obviously
I actually do because like you know
again like as Connor said like you know
we've all been sticking through with
this series for like 10 years right and
you know it's a great [__] show I
love the show but like it's just again
the release order and the way that they
fumbled the bag on that personally
speaking it just kind of lost the hype
for me and I'm just like I mean yeah
I'll get to it eventually I guess but
like I'm not I'm not like gagging to
like finish it you know yeah yeah I I
definitely I felt like in a little bit
of the same boat since the final season
part two just saying it out loud is just
so T yeah I started to kind of check out
a little bit mentally I think I was like
losing my like I was like okay are you
serious yeah I kind of really final
season part two that's I genuinely felt
like it was one of the like more boring
sections of the show for
me because oh my God uh talkie talk
talkie talk don't don't mind him talkie
talk I'm I'm dying here yeah you can you
can take
uh you know there's a there's a very big
reveal at one point during the show uh
to do with uh well there's many big
reveals this oh let's let's let's uh
think about some of like the small
things that happened in uh the second
season oh let's oh wait what was the
opening called again uh the rumbling uh
that's that's like a tiny event that
didn't have any impact on the major
story or anything a song yeah the song
was the best part of that I'll be real I
the rumbling when that started happening
I I felt like it was genuinely just
boring there is so much we got to unpack
here why um boring yeah I I I kind of
liked there was the reveal before this
where it was revealed that Aaron had an
ability that we didn't know about um
that was that had a bearing on the
entire story and I thought that was
really cool and then they just started
going on and on about the backstory
about where this all came from and it
just started to feel like I was like and
I know I know it's not but it started
feeling like super bloated for me in a
way that I then also didn't care about
the rumbling because I it felt like oh I
know I know that how this is going to
end like this feels like it's it's going
in a very clear Direction and they made
and to me it was like okay Attack on
Titan was always at its best when you
didn't know where it was going yeah and
you had no idea what was happening next
see and I felt like that once the mbling
started it was kind of set into this
motion uh where I I thought it was just
going to go a direction and it
absolutely just did go the the what I I
mean it's it's a very safe direction is
the direction it went in I was so
checked out watching that season I don't
even remember
that and it felt like
they just like you were talking about it
what am I dealing with you were talking
about it and I'm like oh yeah that did
happen I just wasn't paying attention
Okay there was a few episodes in that
season where I felt like they were just
[__] wasting time I I think the
complete [__] opposite really because
like I when I saw everyone was very
annoyed cuz one thing I did notice I
somehow managed to go spoiler 3 so I
didn't know
anything somehow I went into spoiler 3
as well however I did know that people
did not like the ending yeah and
therefore I thought the ending was going
to be something kind of weird or kind of
unusual but to me I felt like the ending
was about as safe as you could have gone
uh yeah to me the ending uh I can see
why people had issues with it cuz I
certainly thought that okay I I I think
I really like the ending I thought it
was very messy uh in the way it was like
well that's getting me excited to watch
it it was messy but it was literally the
safest outcome it was like if you're if
you're telling a story and you wanted to
wrap this up how do you do it in the way
that you think will probably be the most
conclusive in like a and will satisfy
yeah and will kind of be like a nice
little bow on the story right right um
so that's what I felt I don't know but
yeah I agree with was convoluted and
kind of blow I think it was messy yeah
it was it was like it was it was messy
well we'll get to the ending like
eventually but cuz I I I can't let go of
this like final season part two yet okay
um sure sure sure because you know I
thought that I'm trying to think of if
there was like a weak point of it and I
would say the part that disinterested me
the most is probably like the law Parts
um how I describe the law parts of
Attack on Titan with the Titans and
stuff like that it kind of felt like
okay you're watching a horror movie and
then there's like this mystery monster
right and then they reveal the mechanics
of the monster and you're like ah the
charm's kind of gone you know it's it's
kind of like you have to do it because
hey you've built this mystery up and hey
you need some kind of explanation but
there will never be kind of like that
kind of so you can't look at Titans with
the same kind of fear or Mystique or
whatever I don't know why they couldn't
have just gone the EO Juni rout and just
never explained the mechanics and just
left it a mystery I mean so much of the
they building up to explaining it yeah
yeah they were building up to explaining
it and uh that was definitely like my
least let's say the the part of attack
that was interested in the least pretty
boring floated um but I still I still
thought it was like pretty interesting
in terms of what that meant for you know
each character and how each character
deals with these
Revelations the [__] rumbling and
especially one of my favorite parts of
final season part two wasn't so much the
event of the rumbling itself it's how
you have all these characters you've
built up all these like two in my mind
interesting characters and you just get
to see how everyone in their own way
deals with it and tries to cope with it
you know I thought that I I thought you
you this is what happens when you just
take great characters and put them in an
interesting situation uh one of my
favorite scenes is uh just when a bunch
of these characters are just sitting
around a fire pit
no action just pure dialogue and I was
just like they are just talking and
discussing what happened and
discussing all the journeys they took to
get there and it's just this is like
compelling television when you just when
you have characters that have built up
you've built up this much that all you
need to do is just put them in the room
together and you're like all right
Magic's going to happen know yeah and I
I enjoyed that segment uh it was when
they in during the final season part two
they get to this dock Village uh and
that's when I was like what the [__]
this is so boring uh docking Village get
to the the village with the port sorry
oh yeah uh I love that scene what do you
mean it's it's like it's like seven
episodes where they're like at this
place it's so long I don't know how many
episodes it is you mean you mean one
where they're stealing the boats yeah
but they they're around that area for
quite a while and I was like hurry the
[__] up oh yeah that did
happen I was like what are you guys
talking about I'm just like yeah I'm
trying not to get too spoiled
but there's just this yeah and and to me
Attack on Titan I think the best season
of Attack was season 3 yeah season 3
part two I agree with that what season 3
part two which which one is that it was
it was two parts remember oh right
right I was like why I I I kind the
ending of season 3 I think I think of
all of that as three I I don't know no
was two it's two parts there two parts
right what was a year in between yeah
season three part two I suppose yeah is
what I'm referring to is my favorite but
also part one of season 3 was also
really really good oh yeah it's one part
three sorry Season 3 pop one and two I
really likeed the most and that's when
it was I think at its best for me and
then we had that big reveal uh with
Aaron and then it slowly started to like
taper off for me in terms of interesting
CU I felt like then they started the the
or it turned into a different show yeah
it was more it was more about why the
[__] this thing is giving Titan powers
and then suddenly I felt like wow this
is the weakest part of the show yet and
I watched season two of the show no I
think the weakest part was like season
one I think season one you kind of get
like I haven't rewatched it so I think
if I went back and rewatched it I might
think it's it's way worse yeah um I
think like I just need to binge all the
seasons now this I you need to go back
and binge and come back to this
conversation this is like I CU this is
like 10 years of scatterbrain memor
trying to critique a show when I was
[__] 17 and I watched it the only
thing I remember is the dub scream from
En yeah I mean cuz I have like rewatched
the show multiple times maybe not like
the en maybe not like the entirety like
recently but I before like the last time
I rewatched the show was before the
final season came out I was like I need
to refresh because it's been a long time
um totally worth it for me I I actually
think I might have enjoyed it more
during my rewatch because now that you
have now that you have the context of
all the reveals and everything that was
kind of like part of the mystery of like
eron's basement and stuff like that you
realized holy [__] this was all planned
from the start yeah you can see all the
little hints now right yeah yeah yeah
yeah there are so many hints from season
one that that out of context I just like
completely blanked on cuz I'm like this
scene makes no sense why why is seen it
and then you watch it you're like oh
[__] this is like final season stuff
what the fck he knew from the beginning
yeah yeah yeah it's it's it's insane
rewatching all of ATT Attack on Titan
yeah I do I do want to get back but you
know part of part of the thing I reason
I think season 1 was uh the weakest is
mostly just because you are kind of like
setting up the world and the characters
and it did like Aaron was at that time a
much more boring character oh God he's
so boring um was just a child I mean I
mean [__] [__] children bro yeah yeah
[__] children I mean the the point is
you had to establish him as like an
angry angsty teenager uh who just was
like [__] prone to violence and um it
was the initial hook it like it's and
like at the time I was just like oh he's
just like every other edgy Shonen
protagonist out there um and then you
see his growth and evolution and that's
where the payoff comes in but still
season one I it's it's it it was more
exciting because of the action scenes um
rather than the kind of like me being
engrossed by all the character writing
and everything that character writing
everyone used to say that it was Game of
Thrones of anime that because Game of
Thrones at the time was really big wa
who the [__] was saying that everyone
was saying everyone everyone was saying
everyone was like it's like Game of
Thrones for anime everyone's dying it's
like it's like people die equals Game of
Thrones oh because that was the that was
like the that was what dominated the
sphere of conversation in like early uh
2010s it's like gaming with difficulty
ah it's the Dark Souls Dark Souls it's
the Dark Souls of hentai game Thrones
with less tears not
come
um character writing okay it's
interesting you say that you think
season one was the weakest because I
think the general consensus when
everyone is comparing all the seasons to
one another I think the major consensus
is a lot of people say season 2 was the
weakest uh season 2 was when I actually
started getting invested in It season 2
was when I kind of realized that oh
these characters are actual like
characters with depth uh and their own
goals and it was a series that was
willing to put focus on other people
rather than than what I thought they
were there was also just a lot less
action in season 2 as well I think
that's what like kind pushed a lot of
people back yeah season 2 was set up but
even so just seeing like the focus on
Yan Historia who were a big part of
season 2 and I remember like watching
season 2 I was like okay when are they
going to get back to like Levi and uh
and the main character characters big
three who who are these two little
lovers who uh I we didn't see anything
about in like the
I think also cuz it was there was a
foure wait I think right between four
year wait four year which was like and
every everyone was [__] waiting for
the second season and then that's what
came out and I think people were like
what the [__] yeah and then I I think it
really hit me at the end when I was like
[__] I actually really care about these
two people maybe even more so than the
main characters and I was like oh okay
this is this I'm actually getting
invested like properly invested in
someone because before when you have a
character death in season one it was
just like a aha we've we've known this
person person for like one episode like
uh you know like oh oh it's the Levi
squads oh wait no no it's just Lev okay
yeah it's just Levi and I'm like I guess
that's sad you know but it it like it
was obviously like very impactful mostly
I think because of like the direction
and the music and everything but how
much I actually cared about anyone who
got off in season 1 was just like yeah
it was all like shock Factor where
season 2 actually started giving a [__]
about characters started giving a [__]
about characters that had absolutely no
screen time in season one and then like
the absolute [__] balls of this man
to do one of the biggest reveals um just
in like a piece of like side dialogue do
you remember this the Betrayal scene oh
yes and then you know you know you were
expecting this kind of like big reveal
to be like haha I am this person it is I
it is I it was me all
along was just like by the way it's me
yeah yeah and yeah and in Attack on
Titan it was just like a piece of
dialogue that was going on in the
background and you had to like literally
double take to be like wait wait did he
just did did what did and and and I was
like this is like the most genius way to
do like a big plot reveal like I've ever
seen cuz they like completely subverted
expectations so like even season 2 was
like the slower season had so many like
amazing point one of the best moments in
the show yeah I think it was a really
highlight yeah I think I feel like you
know the I remember cuz there was a time
when I think it was just season that had
come out and a lot of people were
comparing it to season one and being
like and you know obviously not knowing
where the story was going so they looked
at season 2 which you know had a lot
more new characters that you had to get
yourself you know invested into and less
action so people were immediately like H
season 2 not as great as season one but
again like I think it's after when until
after season 3 came out that people
realized that it was just a set up for
season 3 and then everyone I I think
that's when the appreciation for season
2 slowly started to come back but there
still a lot of people who say season 2
was their least favorite yeah yeah I I
can see why generally overall it was but
maybe maybe the final season part two is
my least favorite I don't know yeah I
mean I think uh I don't know I can't
really think of a season I really like
didn't like you know there are like
weaker Seasons but overall the final
season as a whole I think the latter
half I think there was like still like
super like interesting things happening
like to me like the rumbling and all
like the reaction around that um
I think season 4 was just really
compelling character drama before that I
was still like really really invested in
the action scenes as well like you know
seeing like humans versus Titans season
4 I it was just like huh war is war is
war war never changes and stuff like
that I'm like okay I've seen I've seen
this kind of thing before uh the action
scenes which were equally as hype I was
actually less interested in the action
scenes than just seeing characters well
yeah because it turned into a human Dr
yeah yeah it's just seeing characters
like talk to each other some of my
favorite scenes in season 4 were just
dialogue scenes like erand uh eron like
talking to um Rina in the basement that
was just like you could just cut the
tension with a knife in that scene and I
was like this is this is just compelling
television and I [__] love it um so I
don't think that there was a bad season
of Attack on Titan I think there were
weaker Parts but I think overall Attack
on Titan to me with this ending which I
was very very scared of because I had
heard of the um opinions of the manga
readers but now that I've watched it I
don't think it was the greatest ending
in the world but I think it did the job
and I think most importantly it kind of
like cemented that attack on Titan to me
is is kind of like a modern classic you
know I think yeah they should stick The
Landing right I I think you don't you've
already got such a crazy story and
the a backstory that is really already
way way complicated and I feel like you
just just do a simple ending right don't
don't do anything crazy I think that's
what they went for yeah um what did you
think of the ending yeah I thought it
was fine it was exactly what I thought
was going to happen like the moment with
the fourth season part one where the
[__] started it was just clear that it
was going there like it was there like
you know I I couldn't see it the fact
that there could have been another
alternative ending but I don't think
they would have gone for it try to
challenge it or no it felt very obvious
what was going to happen cuz is it true
that the ending to the anime is slightly
different slightly different so I I had
to look into this cuz I was like I I
need to know why the [__] manga readers
were so pissed off right uh some of it
completely [__] stupid and invalid uh
like it got to the point like the
complaints or the ending um the
complaints oh right right like I like
from what I understand and mang readers
you can you can tell me if I'm wrong cuz
I didn't experience oh they will okay
yeah there there are some things where
um I'm like there was one line can I can
I say this line sure sure okay spoiler
then there there was a line that was
changed from the manga to the anime and
it was a line where Armen thanked Aon
for becoming a mass
murderer what is he what is he a true
crime
YouTuber that was based content Aaron
you did a good job kind of high 20 part
out of this than yo your KD ratio
through the roof and I'm
like that's that's a spicy line right
there um so so they changed that in the
anime yeah so they they changed that in
the anime to just um Arman telling AR uh
sorry Arman telling uh aarin that hey
see you in hell [__] right and
uh you know it's I I kind of understood
makes more sense yeah yeah I kind of
understood like the intention of that
line which was just Armen kind of like
like trying to even though he knows
Aaron's a [__] bad guy and did all
this bad [__] that he tried to take some
of that guilt along with him because he
still sees him as a friend right the
line just came out it just doesn't
translate I mean there's like I I wonder
if there was a translation thing as well
I mean I'm I'm not sure the original I
need a seen in Japan I'm I'm not sure
but I think some of it was just that
there was just so much kind of like
anticipation for the ending right that I
don't think any amount of hype that
mangeras had the expectations uh was
going like was going to be met by the
manga ending at all um because I think
luckily manga readers took the L for us
because I think pretty much all of our
expectations were tempered a little bit
yeah yeah uh because because we saw what
the manga readers how manga we have the
exact line uh Arman says thank you for
turning yourself into a mass murderer
for our sake oh it's even worse than
what I said
for Al's sake oh and uh you say I'm
Express his regret towards this line of
dialogue admitting the intent of the
woods didn't come across as as he yeah
yeah it is crazy how you just [__] up
one line of dialogue and it's like well
uh every thinks your story sucks yeah
yeah um but I yeah I imagine if he
regrets it then I imagine he probably
told the anime staff or what they had a
he like Hey I what I meant to do
something different here this episode is
sponsored by expresso UPN Bo have you
seen the Japanese yen exchange rate
right now if you don't know the Japanese
Yen has tanked for us and we need to
save every Yen that we can especially
when it comes to services that come from
abroad guys it's so easy to have those
streaming services prices just to add up
think about it Netflix Disney plus
Amazon Prime you name it all of them are
just offering the same thing but with
Express VPN you don't need them anymore
see all these streaming services like
Netflix actually have thousands of more
shows than you think you just don't see
them because they give you different
shows depending on your country so what
you see on Netflix in Japan for example
is going to be completely different to
say something you'll see in Italy or
South Korea but using the expressvpn app
you can change your online location
whenever you want I can you can G
expressvpn is over 90 countries to
choose from so every time you run out of
shows to watch you can just switch to
another country and unlock completely
new shows see guys now that we live in
Japan most of the anime I want to watch
is on Netflix but whenever I go abroad I
have to sign up to other subscription
Services when I just say I'm there for
like weeks but thanks to express VPN
every time I'm abroad I can just tune in
to Japanese Netflix and watch free Ren
right here thank God it's a no-brainer
so if you want to get way more shows and
save money while you're at it go to
expressvpn.com traste don't forget to
use our link so you can get 3 months
extra for free that's e x p SS vpn.com
trashtaste exess vpn.com traste to learn
more back to the episode yeah yeah I
mean like I I still have my quals with
the ending I think there are like it was
there was a lot that was presented into
presented to us within this ending and I
think a big problem was that the mystery
of season 4 so every like season had the
mystery that they were building up
towards and the Mystery for season 4 was
what the [__] was Ain doing like this
entire time right we we really did not
know what he was thinking and then he
kind of like dumped 20 million different
things like to us in about like 5
minutes or something and I'm like I
don't I get it I think there's yeah yeah
his motivation felt very like I just
want a genocide yeah like I just think
it's a good idea and it's
like why at the at the beginning it was
like it kind of felt like I just want a
genocide oh no Waits I wanted you guys
to do this oh no Waits I needed to enact
this timeline because my mind is [__]
up there is there was just there was
just a lot zero
planning it it it almost felt like like
every part of Attack on Titan had been
planned up until like this point uh
because before that it just felt like
everything had been so meticulously
planned and then you got to this point
and it just kind of felt like um let's
just throw a bunch of things at the wall
and maybe something is going to like
stick with everything but like to me it
kind of felt confusing where if you just
had like a few extra scenes just to tell
me what was going through Erin's mind I
think that would have like cleared
things up perfectly I had this thought I
don't know is like Blasphemous to say
this when I when they were kind of doing
a bunch of the ending stuff on the final
season I remember sitting there thinking
like man I feel like if this was Hunter
Hunter like his way of explaining things
I'd be so into this it's just a
different way toi toi bu different I
just to the way that Togashi explains
stupidly like the way that he'll tell me
something complicated that I know is
dumb but he'll just make it seem so cool
you can say great Island it's all right
there's so many things that he so many
of his stories that he presents them in
a way where I'm like I know this is dumb
but man it's it just seems so cool in
this world and I'm so into it and I felt
like with the Yim backstory [__] I felt
like man if if toosi was writing this I
feel like I'd be so into it but but I
was watching it and I was like man I
just don't give a [__] about the you
[__] backstory of this stupid girl I
didn't I jally just didn't care I was
that was easily the worst part of the
show for me yeah yeah yeah so you know
kind of kind of kind of here uh and it
was the only like if this you know this
it was an a banger of a show it was
really the only part that really started
to make me lose interest was was that
yeah like so what you're saying is you
would have liked it if Togashi had
written it if he had just subbed in let
him like Sub in and I'm wondering like
wait why is there a narrator come
tit but I'm down it'd be so hype if if
Aaron's mental was narrated about why he
wanted to do war cry
instead and then Aaron wanted to kill
everyone but something changed Aaron in
this
millisecond seen something that y had
possessed in Aon was like don't worry
guys I'll become a mass murderer for
your sakes I got this I'll shoulder the
sins on myself and then the narrator
would tell me why and I'd be like this
so cool if toi wrot this toi wrote that
L every
likeed it would it
would are you saying you wanted things
even more explained you or well I I I
don't know cuz I was I watched this
video I wanted to be
explained
better I did have to like there was a
few times where I had to go back and
watch half of the episode again in part
two to be like what the [__] yeah like
to fully comprehend what's happening
yeah and I feel like that's it's good
and bad thing it's like cool that you
have a show that that is so so much
depth to it that I almost have to pause
and have a think but also very annoying
that I watched this first and I maybe
I'm just done which is probably very
reasonable assumption here to make but
I'm when I'm watching it I'm just like
man I'm just confused like well I think
that's the problem when you add so many
like different elements because you know
I think the advantage the early season
had was like the Simplicity and with the
final season um you it was already
complex enough with the political stuff
um that was already great and that was
what I was interested in and then you
add this the Titan mechanics with time
traveling and inheriting wheels and all
this [__] and like if you like think
about it deeply you kind of are just
like it starts to just get more
confusing as you know as every and L
compelling I think yeah yeah to me to
like to me that's that was never why I
liked Attack on Titan that was never the
main focus I know some people love into
go into LW diving but like like for me
one of the things that bothered me that
I please explain Attack on Titan LW
experts if I'm misunderstanding
something but you know know in season 4
where you know every descendant of the
royal had like special was was the only
one that could take on the powers of the
special found whatever right um and then
this explained that every every um
eldian or is that the right wordan yeah
yeah every eldian is comes from the same
person yamir so how do you distinguish
between who's Royal and who's not when
they all share the same bloodline like I
I I couldn't understand I couldn't
understand what what like what made the
difference between a royal and just a
normal person that shared blood from the
same Creator I was just like ah I can
already see the manga readers on the
comments like it's in the it's in the
inner Linings of the manga you have to
the manga it got to the point where I
was like man I'll just wait for the
YouTube Lord deep die explainer like
I'll just wait cuz like I don't I feel
like I'm not prepared for this story the
digo anime video time and then and then
when you get to that point where you
start like breaking down the mechanics
that's when I start to get less
interested because it's it I need a 1
hour YouTube video to explain it kind of
that CU it it just like kind of like
detracts from uh what the story's trying
to tell either because and it feels like
it almost like it almost had to be
written this way because he had to
explain something about it you know uh
but that was to me that was never the
main strength of Attack on Titan as a
story um and now yeah now with this
ending yeah I was completely satisfied
um I think it could have been EX a b a
little bit cleaner most of it had to do
with had to do with law stuff had to do
with like law stuff I'm not going to lie
uh but in terms of like all the
character
resolutions um I was happy with the
ending we got I know it's they stuck The
Landing could you say I'd say they
landed on two feet okay yeah yeah that's
good they might have like stumbled along
the way but they didn't fall over you
know they they finish it off off I just
realized whenever in that goddamn
[__] sand realm with the tree that's
when I that's when I was like [__] this
epod is going to be boring whenever they
whenever they go to this like uh I don't
know type in Attack on Titan y world or
something yeah yeah this is this is
[__] uh let me yeah this whenever
whenever they [__] go here I I I just
I'm like God this episode's going to be
boring but cool background
though actually like it it's funny
because the final season kind of like
the the actual final episode uh that we
got that was probably my least favorite
part um of Attack on Titan um the action
was kind of
boring it it looked gorgeous it looked
gorgeous but I felt like I know what's
going to happen here come on do you know
what it felt like it felt like you know
when you watch a Marvel movie and like
some Marvel movies have like really
interesting concept third act fight yeah
yeah yeah and you're like and then you
get to the third act fight you're like
all right all right this big CGI battle
all right all right wrap it up let's
wrap it we know they're going to win it
up come on oh No Doctor Strange is going
to
lose a no
way crazy yeah that that was kind of
like my feel like compared to that I I
will take this cuz this actually has
like some interesting character moments
in there like some of the path stuff but
like the final battle I was like yeah it
looks it looks great it looks funny uh
nothing's really interesting is
happening with the characters so it's
just action scene so it's pretty
fireworks which is the way you should
you know conclude a show or whatever but
I was waiting for how the ending ending
was meant to happen which yeah was great
question to you guys let's uh let's from
yeah how much do you think the ending
really matters cuz I was I was going to
ask this you Joey which is you haven't
seen the ending yet yeah how much would
how much is the ending and how much can
the ending affect your opinion on like
everything that Ser I think the ending
is very very important I think when
people talk about overall fantastic
shows that become memorable a lot of
people think about the ending like there
are so many Fantastic there are so many
like you know great decent even
fantastic shows that we had which had a
really [__] horrible ending which
just completely ruined the entire
reputation of the show even though the
show up until that point was pretty
decent you know like look at like uh
dead Manu land for instance right like
pretty decent show up until the last
couple of episodes and then it just
[__] ruins everything whereas well I
mean the actually deine just never got
well yeah that's what I mean the manga
was bad there yeah the manga was a lot
better right but like um no the manga
sucked the manga was better than the
anime it was better yeah yeah it was the
but not by much right like but like you
know just having even a good or decent
ending does wonders for a show look at
like you know why do you think like say
like code yes for instance is still
talked about to this day goed ending
it's most stories always go for a safe
ending think about most stuff you watch
they always go for the the ending that
is kind of being telegraphed the entire
time but I would rather take a a safe
ending than a [__] ending you know like
it's very risky correction most anime I
watch don't even get endings oh yeah so
actually just getting an ending in and
of itself is actuallyy [__] deal I
actually think I don't care about
endings that much I feel like it's more
about the journey and if a show is a bad
ending I'll probably remember that but
it's so rare it's so rare that an
amazing show will be amazing all the way
through and then just have a [__] ending
yeah because I was like I I think I had
this thought you know with Attack on
Titan because you know even with some of
the weirdest stuff that happened in the
like sorry even with some of the stuff
they changed from the manga ending to
the anime ending they weren't that much
different you know it wasn't that much
different um and I remember thinking
like you know when we talk about Bad
Endings everyone brings up Game of
Thrones and that wasn't a bad ending
that was a bad few seasons that also had
a bad ending yeah it was leading up to
being like terrible so when when when
everyone's like man the ending of G is
so bad I think they just meant like you
know you going into the final season you
didn't feel good about it yeah that was
like a good three seasons of going
downhill to like a final season I I just
thought of an example of an amazing show
that had a pretty crummy ending what yuu
Hawk
show but was it remember was it like the
last few that's how lack the last few
moments leading up to it were lackluster
was it literally just amazing right
until it ends it was my opinion what was
wrong with the ending it was [__]
rushed even Togashi said it was rushed
it was okay but
like it had it had so much potential and
it just [__] fumbled itself in my
opinion yeah I mean the final Arc was
weak as hell compared to everything that
came the final AR had so much potential
and then it just was like yeah never
mind we're done I mean like it just kind
of ended I wouldn't say it was like a
bad end you know people like with the
attack on Titan endings uh especially
with what I read about mongaras they
were just like oh this has ruined the
entire series for me and I'm like can
can a final scene or can a final chapter
actually change the like change the like
your perception of an entire series I do
think it can if you do a bad enough job
uh I also think though it's not fair
with Attack on Titan because I think the
expectations of every Anime Watcher and
every Attack on Titan fan was just
astronomically but but I also think that
like let's say you you read that line
from Armen where he just goes against I
guess his entire
character that happened in Game of
Thrones as well with Jamie like they're
one of the big criticisms that in the
very last scene in Game of Thrones they
kind of this character who'd been having
this whole Redemption Arc for the past
few seasons just just says something
that literally goes against everything
that he'd been building up to and then
it's kind of like a slap in the face and
I imagine that's probably why some of
the fans got very annoyed at atat Titan
is that hey we have this character who
we've been learning so much about for
the past 10 years and then he says one
thing that is like wait what the [__]
right it's like you know it's like
finding out a friend that you like play
[__] valerant with just war crimes
you're like what the [__] I thought we
were kidding we should we like this what
the
hell weird examp do you have a friend
like that long story long
story you know it's like I would
actually say more accurate analogy would
probably be like oh you find out your
friend revant is like a Nazi
sympathizer that that is like literally
what it would be yeah you're like a lot
of the stuff start to make sense now
they definitely exist like uh yeah I
think that you can do stuff that ruins
characters Kanye
fans I mean bro look at his music dude
no one plays that [__]
anymore that is true Kanye Kanye is a
great example can you can do stuff that
ruins the story and the characters
ending but he made CR
situation season 1 Kane was the
best holy [__] oh my God sorry um I
think again like when it attack on time
I feel is a very special instance in the
anime world because again it had so much
of a dedicated fan base and it was such
a long running series that the
expectations for it to do the perfect
triple axle at the end and land the you
know land it completely like 10 out of
10 yeah was almost expected with how
much the show was hyping itself up and
how much the fans were hyping itself up
so I think it's kind of a double-edged
sword of like when the show gets that
popular and that hyped up and the fans
are expecting only the best thing from
it and they don't get exactly the most
mindblowing ending imaginable even if it
was like a good ending right like a a
perfectly fine safe ending as you guys
put it right I think it still
undervalues itself compared to how
people wanted it to to actually be and
so people look at that and go well it
wasn't exactly mind-blowing AKA it
wasn't great yeah and then that's where
the criticism start I feel cuz like I
feel like you know I don't know how many
times we've experienced an anime ending
where it's just kind of like completely
changed our perception because most of
the time when we watch a long running
show get to an end the show has already
done everything it's needed to do and
the last like 10 kind of like percent of
that is just like okay I am finishing
this just just because I just want to
close this chapter you know which I
which is what I feel like a lot of
people who are watching the final
episode of Attack when Titan fell they
just wanted to close this chapter off um
because they had been such a big part of
their lives uh for like the last 10
years you know but it is possible to
have like that ending that the fans
watching that show and have been
following that show with you know kind
of look at and go okay that is
definitely for one almost uh you know
goes beyond our expect of the show even
though we had high expectations for it
and was not necessarily like the safe
way to end it like again like I'm going
to bring back code yes again because
like the ending of season 2 I think a
lot of people watched that when it was
even airing and was like holy [__] that
ending is insane like so many people
weren't expecting that ending and that
show was already a very popular show and
had very high expectations for it to
stick the landing and I think it oh the
execution was insane the execution I
dare say was perfect it easily could
have been [__] stupid though oh
absolutely I think the ending was one of
those that I could see it going really
badly yeah definitely just perfect but I
feel like they also uh you know the the
they also took a risk with that ending
as well to and cuz that could have gone
South very easily but they were just in
that lucky position where they managed
to create something that was unique and
memorable and amazing which is very
difficult to do you know and now they're
bringing him back so that's [__] cuz
cuz like you talked about uak show and I
remember thinking um I don't necessarily
remember too much of the ending I just
remember the Last Arc being weak uh but
what I do remember was just like doesn't
really matter like UW show still goated
you know no still goed yeah yeah that
didn't like changed my perception of uwk
show at all but it's also a different
kind of story I guess because you know I
I think the problem with yuu Hawk show
was that it kind of cut itself short at
the moment where it could have turned
into something amazing whereas like
clearly togashi's heart was not in it
for the final Arc um you know dark the
the Dark Tournament Arc I think he put
100% of his effort in and if he had
ended it there would have been goated
like no complaints whatsoever I think
the fact that he went on to half ass
this final Arc yeah kind of just made it
be like
so basically it's it's a thing that
happens a lot in Shon and jump which is
just they kind of just cut it off oh B
of it yeah no matter what that's like
that's how we get the [__] awful
endings in anime like all right pack it
up CH like wrap it up guys wrap it up um
done yeah like I remember my most recent
like holy [__] this ending is [__]
bad is um probably promis Neverland
season 2 so no not not even promise
Neverland season 2 promise Neverland the
manga oh the manga the manga yeah where
cuz I know Season 2 ending we don't talk
about that it was season two ending was
just like that was just something
different that was a bad adapation but
season uh like the final arcs of
promised Netherlands that was just kind
of It kind of took what was like to me I
don't know if it was rushed it kind of
felt like it was rushed 90% of Bad
Endings in my opinion Rush uh kind of
like it it feels like it's rushed right
yeah I mean you can't you can't spend
like 500 [__] episodes [__] around
in some field in some anime and then
just have 20 episodes be the ending
you're like what yeah yeah
like one piece if it ever ends going to
have to do like a [__] 500 chapter
lead up otherwise people are going to be
like it's rushed I think that's what
they currently doing yeah probably you
like you have like it has it has to be
such a giant Arc to end it otherwise
people would be like nah it's Rush well
I think a lot of the issues with anime
endings especially when it comes to like
action Focus so I'm going to bring up a
very very old anime that I don't know
how many people have watched this uh but
the anime is called bus Rankin I've
heard of this goed you've seen it yo
that's going back to the anime man days
man love this um what PL about I
honestly I do not remember it's it's
shown in Jump from like 2003 2004
something but like the important thing
about that ending that like I remember
was that normally in like an anime
ending you have the final episode be
like action focused like it was in
Attack on Titan for example where you
have the final climax scene and that's
the final ending to the show Yu-Gi-Oh
that's so nostalgic this is
nostalgic like Yu-Gi-Oh it's nostalgic
as hell the reason I remember this one
is because this entire final episode was
just epilog just tying up lense no and
I'm like why do more shows not do this
why do you have to feel like hey this
final episode has to have action in it
because that's the climax not every
action anime has to end with the main
characters fighting with the opening
playing over you know yeah exctly you
can tell the after Story it's fine I
think another re another one of the
anime goats the ending is so good is uh
G as you know for metal archist
Brotherhood has a great ending it does
it does have a good ending great ending
has an epilogue it's really [__] good
it does it does have good it ties up the
story so godamn well and I think it's a
reason why that show also has been
remembered as one of the greats I I
agree with that I think the ending is
just really good yeah I don't I don't
know like I don't know why more shows
don't do like EP I'm not being like when
I say epilog I don't mean like oh one or
two like scenes of like what they're
doing but like no dedicate an entire
[__] episode on what these characters
are getting up to we have been invested
in these characters for this long do you
think we don't care enough to sit down
and just check out what their lives are
going to be like after the big massive
fight after the big massive event no I
[__] love that [__] just hearing the
characters talk over and reminiscing
over those final events is already
interesting enough where people like oh
okay so that's how they felt about it
you know and now it can it creates this
nice close to be like well you know what
they're alive they're doing good I'm
happy for them cool exactly right that's
all we need that that to me brings more
closure than like tie having to tie up
every [__] loose end and ending off
in a big climax cuz cuz not every ending
has to be code gas not every ending has
to be [__] Cowboy bbop where it ends
on like a single iconic moment sometimes
you all you need to do is is just let
the characters have the send offs they
deserve let them cook have the send offs
they deserve and just let them like
wallow in that moment for a bit longer
than one single scene that's that's what
I want I think I've just been [__]
conditioned to just getting used to
shows that don't get endings Yeah well
yeah because that's the majority of end
yeah you know like I watched all of
House of
Cards and then you know what's house of
cards again remember the netfli the
firsto oh
Kevin
spyy I just watch it and loads of shows
around that time just kind of fizzled
out that you would just watch like lost
I never [__] finished yeah what's
some endings you remember then like
anime not film I'd love to I'd love to
say it what it like it's such a cop out
answer Breaking Bad was such a good
ending Breaking Bad was a good ending
that was that was a good ending I really
like that ending like that that was
probably one of the few endings that
didn't necessarily do anything Grand it
just tied up everything in a neat
package you know um cuz when you know
when I think of endings that stick out
my mind you think about things like code
gear or uh the ending of like usual
suspects or [__] six cents or stuff
like that something where something
iconic happens at the end but seven yeah
yeah seven seven you know you I think
it's easier to type a movie in general
than it is to watch oh we're talking
we're talking like shows we're talking
anything what are some like endings that
stick out in your mind as like some of
like the goated endings you know I think
I was I'm so bad at this I can't
remember yeah cuz like to me like I I
named out most of the endings that stuck
out to me in terms of like movies uh in
terms of like anime obviously like
cowboy bbop was one um and everything
else I'm I know I'm forgetting something
you know you know that feeling where you
know you're forgetting like something I
know forgetting like at least like three
or four you know we think of code gears
we think of stuff like C I can't think
of many other iconic anim endings that
didn't just hey we tied up every loose
end like like GE and the gun was
something was that was just like hey we
tied up every loose end you know
remember not for the ending but for
episode 16 right when that happens was
pretty fun there no spoilers but when
when they were throwing galaxies at each
other that was kind of that was [__]
pry I actually wish that got more of an
epilogue actually but that was that was
kind of a hype climax as well that was
true yeah yeah um I'm I'm trying to
think of cyber Punk pretty good I like
cyber Punk was that what was the ending
oh the Ed R is ending yeah yeah was that
a good ending I like that ending I
remember being a good Andy I like that I
like the message of [__] you you're not
special we we need more we need more
things with some real takes I'm tired
about hearing the chosen one I don't
care about the chosen one I want to hear
about Average Joe who gets too close to
the sun do you do you think more endings
just have their like sad endings I love
I love endings that are [__] up
endings that like leave you feeling h
yeah cuz I feel like that sticks with me
so much longer than you don't like the
school days
Andy
that that you literally just describe
the school days in here hypocrite that's
just [__] your way out of like [__]
off
yeah speaking a great I'll say forner
speaking a great ending first of all
yeah first of all not a great ending I I
that ending was has to be a good series
has a good ending Joey you didn't say
anything like that that ending could
have been like the roest [__] if the
previous five episodes weren't dog yeah
but it was the roest [__] no but it
would have been [__] cool if it was
good show that's one of the rare
occasions where the show is [__] but the
ending is goed like I yeah okay credit
to the ending was [__] weird to the
point where I can't forget it I I do
want more endings where I'm like what
the [__] yeah totally I I think those
kinds of endings stick with you for a
lot longer because you know I've seen
enough endings that are like happy
endings or like some Sumer pretty much
most most endings that I can remember
are kind of like Bittersweet you know I
I feel I feel like that's the meta you
know even Attack on Titan most most
anime endings for me are just like it
they're just almost unmemorable like
they they end off in a way where it's
not 100% conclusive but it's not 100%
left in the you know it's like it's like
the 80s Freeze Frame equivalent of an
ending where it's just like yep I guess
that's the end now cool you know not
it's nothing special like or nothing
special all memorable in either a good
or a bad sense you know right cuz I'm
trying to think of a manga that's a
manga rning that actually stuck out to
me cuz I don't see anime ends um ending
I'm reading that by the way the last you
reading that the last chapter is goed oh
really yeah I'm trying to
remember just I'll let I'll let you know
what I think yeah let me let me know
what you think about
[Applause]
it oh that was the one with no dialogue
right no dialog okay okay that one was
good and that one he took a risk I like
the Gans sanding was really [__]
weird G I'm trying to remember the G
sanding where they like there's just
they just meet some weird
aliens oh yeah just really [__] weird
yeah that was weird that wasn't the
ending that was like the lead up to the
ending the ending I don't remember that
was the last thing I remember about Gans
my head that's the ending yeah I'm I'm
going to to it quickly and I'm going to
Google iconic endings just in general
this episode it sponsored by Harry there
is a subscription service for
everything from Artisan jerky to all
those streaming subscriptions it feels
like they've lost their real value
saving time and money subscriptions only
really make sense for stuff you use all
the time on the same Cadence like razor
blades and with Harry's you get high
quality German engineered blades right
at the front of your door every order
saves you money compared to the big
brands most guys are used to buying so
get them as low as $2 per blade at
harry's.com
trash taste as we all know I only use
Harry's and I've been using them since
they started sponsoring this show there
a reason why I just like the quality the
shave that I get is by far better than
any other brand I've ever used that's
not [__] i' I've genuinely been
using only Harry's for the past two
years now brand so harri's please send
me more I can't get them in Japan and I
want more get a subscription that saves
you time and money today with Harry's
get started with a $13 trial set at just
$3 at harry's.com trashtaste that's
harry's.com trashtaste for a $3 trial
sets what are you
for Wow Wow Wow Conor wow what are you
waiting for I'm trying to I'm trying to
like trying to Happ no no no it's okay
it's
okay take it that's harry.com traste for
a $3 trial set right now get it press
the link in description back to the
episode Harry all right all right I I I
got I got a list of the top 10 iconic
anime endings of all time sure uh is
this the one oh devil man cry baby had a
[__]
that was that was The Bleak empty ending
that was a
good as well that which is a very
underrated ending as
Wella that was okay that one was okay
that was like an a ending tatami Galaxy
I haven't seen tatami
Galaxy thing I haven't seen paranoid
agents yeah that that had a decent
ending I think it's not it's just not as
memorable as the rest of the show yeah
definitely yeah the ending didn't stand
out as much as the rest of like the
weird ideas of the rest of the show yeah
um got Barak Baran haven't seen that I
mean that's that doesn't have a lot of
story to go off of D I didn't watch I
didn't finish that I didn't finish it
either I'm I'm sad I'm sad now yeah
Hunter Hunter yo that's cap that's what
what's ending what is what there is no
ending all right what's next berser
Naruto Shi yeah so Naruto Shian is like
that's a good example like the narat
ending of just what I mean by just the
most safe cookie cutter ending you could
ask for and that's completely fine you
know you've been with these characters
oh
anohana I feel like it was a safe ending
Anan Andy
yeah I'm trying I'm trying I'm okay okay
wait wait wait I'm trying to remember I
remember crying like a [__] to
this I know I cried like a [__]
but I don't know if that was cuz I was
like an emotional teen I don't know if
it like affects me that much at this day
and age because I remember that I
remember this was like anah was more
like Pavlov's dog it conditioned you
with that one song at the end and then
it like when secet Bas comes on and then
and then at the ending of anaha that the
real I feel like the reason that was
iconic was just because the song just
kept going and going and I was just like
stop I don't have any they all scream I
found you and then the ending starts and
he just
like
why um C
A that had a good ending I [__] love
that show a great [__] show okay goed
goed all right all right what else next
one your line in April I didn't watch
that [__] see this is a very divisive
ending it is cuz a lot of people love
this ending and a lot of people just
thought it was kind of a copout I
thought it was a copout yeah uh I I I've
this is like my hot take where I prefer
the first half of your Li in April
rather than the second half um it really
felt like to me some of like the more
the more interesting part of your in
April to me was seeing someone fall in
love uh with music again yeah and then
there was a big that's why I didn't
watch it yeah and then there was a big
twist because it almost felt like hey
what this character is going through
isn't sad enough we need to make it sad
yeah the character drama of corset I
think like not being able to hear like
the piano and [__] like that that part
was so well written yeah and then they
just had to be like by the way the girl
you love yeah something's going to
happen I'm not going to say it obviously
spoilers but so yeah yeah that's that's
a bit of a call out Stein gate ah okay
Stein gate that's the one we we need to
yeah I I knew I was one was on the like
tip of my tongue Stein Gat I okay that
entire second half is just going Stein
gate to me needs the respect it deserves
for having a time travel story and
somehow wrapping up its like mechanics
and it story in a satisfying manner I
agree you know because most of the time
when you introduce time travel to a
story there is going to be some [__] up
along the way where like to the ending
where it's just like oh that kind of
like plot didn't make sense the
mechanics didn't make sense science game
is pretty much one of the only examples
I can think of where you introduce time
travel and you managed to close the Loop
while making it like seem like
everything was resolved yeah and they
and I think what was genius with Stein
gate is that they did all of that they
somehow managed to tie so many of the
Loose Ends perfectly into one knot while
not making the conclusion obvious for
people who was watching like you had no
idea how that show was going to end even
even as they like gave you all of this
information from like literally multiple
different timelines at the same time I I
I think I think the like I think the
impressive thing about this isn't so
much what happened it's the fact that
they managed to tie everything up yeah
they made it make sense remember liking
it I remember what happens but I
remember liking
it the only bad the only I'd say
negative thing about Stein gate is that
it is a slow burner especially the first
half I remember the first half was so
hard to get through yeah but that but if
you make it through that first half that
entire first 101 episodes is the buildup
it's also it's the SE it's the attack on
TI season two and I know it's I know
it's like intentional but it's so Ray
yeah and then visually very like boring
so it's really hard to like sit there
for like 10 episodes watch them in the
exact same location you're like a where
are my
RG but like that was cuz I got into
anime and I was code guos is like full
goddamn colors and then I went to this I
was like oh this is a lot different why
why are the chin so round they're
talking a lot a lot of it's in the cool
way with the with the
[__]
when is does that happen it's like all
what's next next one death
n no I mean no all for one the ending is
slightly different right it is factually
correct that the second half of death is
weaker than the first half I think it's
a good ending no I think it's a good
ending but it could have been 10 times
better if they if if [__] Nia didn't
exist yeah the [__] was dog I know I I I
agree that the second half was weaker
not even the second half the second like
the last third the I've rewatched e
there quite a few times it is always
just such a like slog in a different
show yeah after the obviously the big
big thing yeah it just kind of sucks but
I think the ending of death no did what
it needed to um and I thought it was a
good ending I thought it both the manga
and the anime cuz I've read both the
manga and the anime um both had
different takes on the ending and both
did something different and uh prefer
the I knew you would Jerry I [__] I
just think it's a better rounded and
better presented ending than the I think
the anime is more cinematic which is why
I kind of prefer the anime ending yeah I
I loved uh the scene where he ran past
his like younger self with the death
note I was just like that was just like
oh that's an anime original I was like a
that's actually really well done I I
kind of like love the visuals of that um
but that's my that's just my opinion bro
yeah scroll down it's all good all right
yeah ass class ask class okay I I like
the ending this I didn't finish this
show so I can't when he does the final
roll call not going to lie kind of tear
up okay I believe it I believe it it was
a feel good show it was it was I think
it was a way better ending than what the
show was expecting you to have expecting
you to see okay so I think yeah this is
underrated all
righty iconic
yeah next one [__] off SC Dragon Ball
Z I mean if we're not including GT I
guess
what yeah we can just keep going let's
keep going we got nothing better G I
haven't finished gint yet all right keep
going yeah okay one's going to be yeah
okay so we were right for the most part
yeah I mean I I don't think endings
matter that much I think as long as you
do a whatever ending you'll be fine
after all of that whatever that don't
matter think about a lot of the shows
you like you remember call middle bits
and the feelings you had you don't
necessarily think of the pl I'm not
saying the ending is everything but I
think it is an important part of a story
that shouldn't be overlooked well yeah
that's saying that like any like the
start is important every part of the
story is important but I I have
something more to add to this okay um
because uh I have just been playing
cyber Punk recently uh I played the uh
played the new expansion which I think
is the best kind of like cyber punks
like thing that has been released uh so
far um and I kind of realized that I
think I hate multiple ending games like
you know what I mean me too me too I
actually kind of despise it because the
the the true ending is always a lot of
[__] you got to do you got to look
up a guide on how to get it and you're
like this sucks why is the ending the
the the always the good endings the ones
you have to go through all the
complicated [__] for yeah because
like I I I remember playing through the
original like the original cyber Punk
and the ending to me was super
unsatisfying uh and I kind of realized
that oh it's just because I made all of
like the worst choices possible I got
like the [__] ending I like and like to
me like even like the fact of the
existence of multiple endings like
demerits the impact of having like one
single ending right cuz you can have
like I guess like a Canon ending a true
ending but just the fact that the the
user or like the viewer can choose their
own ending I think that detracts from
the impact of just there being
one ending did you get what I mean I I
do agree but then I I oh man I really
like that fear and hunger has multiple
endings I think
it's the fear and
H but I really like how they use the
multiple endings in that game but I
hated it in cyberpunk okay actually can
I can I preface the thing that I hate
the most is when you can't do any
choices that affect the ending until
literally like the last moment where
it's like there's so many little things
you can do in like the very last segment
cuz then it feels like a cop out it's
like oh you didn't plan for multiple
endings we just got to this one point
and you felt like we can add a bunch of
depth if in the last two hours of the
game then I think a game that does that
whole multiple ending thing really well
is Catherine because the the thing with
Catherine to get the multiple endings
it's literally from the very first
choice you can make in the game and
everything up until the end matters yeah
and I like how like untale does it like
you know like a meme but undertale did
it in a really good
way immediately from the GetGo
B the wor the worst multiple endings are
the where it's literally the last where
it's like yes or no two different
endings well there like cyber Punk a lot
of not not all the endings but a lot of
them are what you answer in the last few
moments right um yeah I well there's the
it depends where you are there there are
like so many different endings to cyber
punk though yeah and I know there's a
few way if you do all the certain side
quest you get the true ending which is
how it always is but then I know there's
like the when you you can go to space or
you can shoot yourself or other stuff
and I was like man I felt like I've been
locked out of the good ending and all of
these are not fun yeah but I would have
enjoyed it more if I was put on a clear
path that is showing me that I'm going
towards something different from the
start not kind of figuring out cuz like
I remember playing 3D expansion and I
was just like this is actually the Cyber
Punk that I thought I was going to get
from the original game highly [__]
recommended by the way um because it's
[__] incredible how much they've
changed from the um from the first
initial release um and uh obviously
Idris Elba [__] kills it in this role
as well it's he's [__] great but you
get I got to the ending and it was like
the way they closed out the ending I got
was so perfect to how like they built up
the characters and kind of like
metaphorically sent off all the
characters I was like this is [__]
great and then I read up on the other
endings and I was just like man if I got
any of these other endings with like
some of the choices that I made I would
have been like I would have been like
[__] I mean my I remember cuz I the
final big fight in that game at least
the base game I remember when I played
it it was so buggy so I remember
thinking like this espcially the Epic
final boss and he stuck behind the wall
and shoot and I'm shooting him with a
pistol and I'm like man this is just
this is just not how I envisioned this
did this epic glad I Suk the time into
this yeah just man it was yeah it was a
bit sad maybe I should go back and it
out yeah and cuz and I just think I just
think for something very story driven I
guess like cyber punk I it almost
like it almost like like like I said
detracts from the impact of the ending
knowing that hey if you're not happy
with this one just go a different routes
whereas you know you look at like other
games like for example like Last of Us
or you know God of War recently for me
those endings like stuck me because that
was the ending the send off to the
characters no no no redu no no other
Happy Endings no other sad endings that
was the ending that we got right and
that was what made those endings stuck
out to me you know so yeah I think it's
a better way but I guess you have to why
do you like the fear and hunger endings
then I like it because you have to the
they won the character specific so there
four playable characters and they all
have their own version which I which I
like because it utilizes their story to
tell you know not just a backstory
here's your character figure it out it's
like hey your character based off what
we've told you has this Mission if you
go and complete that Miss you'll get a
unique ending which I really like cuz
it's it's setting the goals right from
the GetGo saying this is what you need
to do and it's up to you if you want to
listen to that whereas I felt that like
cyber Punk it's like uh whatever
whatever can Reef tells you to do just
do it yeah and then you'll figure it out
it's like okay okay I don't know but I I
haven't played the DLC and also I
haven't played it since when it came out
basically so I don't know it could be
completely different experience only
presumably it is yeah um I I uh first of
all did you see you see the uh you guys
know I'm I'm a Rob Robert patson simp
did you see he's voicing uh in the new
haki movie oh yeah am did you hear him
he dude he he sounds insane in the do
yeah yeah he sounds insane he doesn't
sound like Rob patson at all he does not
it's insane bro bro popped off uh I just
want to say cuz I watched this movie in
Japanese yeah and I heard his voice and
I was shocked at how good Rob Patterson
got close to the Japanese voice okay
let's see Robert Patterson the boy in
the kind of yo William def foes in it
yeah will the let's go feel I'm actually
watching now yeah I might I might watch
it yeah I I I I you know the movie
actually cuz I think when I came on the
show after I watched this I said it was
all right but I think actually the more
I've sat on it the more it's grown on me
yeah I think I kind of like [__] I need
Watch
thisin come out July yeah dude watched
it I don't I don't think I'm not sure if
it's still in cinemas no I I was going
to watch it but yeah that's the one just
yeah just yeah my what exactly are you
your mother she's awaiting your
rescue that's actually that's sick as
[__] kid um I'm hyped for that I just
want say because I I went to the I I've
been I go to the cinema all the time
because I like watching movies uh even
bad movies I love watching bad movies
too because that's how I have my uh you
know my my kind of you got to appreciate
SC you got to watch the bad to
appreciate the good you know uh so I
watched I watched two films recently I
watched the Martin scorey film um I
really want to watch that all the new
one yeah and it's [__] it's so long it's
three and a half hours right no it's
like 3 hours and 40 something okay I'm
rning up that's what the Irishman was as
well dude the Irishman was like 3 hours
50 or something dude it's so long it was
so long is it worth it um I think
so dude it's one of those movies that
when you come out of it every schoy film
review it's so damn long but it's pretty
good no you kind of leave
and I was just glad it was over like I
I this happens with movies sometimes
that even if it's a really good movie
the moment you you go to check your like
watch or you go to get some kind of time
indication to be like how long have I
been here for where you're like I kind
of I'm getting the feeling I want this
to end and I definitely felt that way
about two two-ish hours in I was like
okay it just takes um uh killers of the
uh killers of flower Moon he of the
flower Moon
um I mean I won't spoil anything but I
actually think I for once in in a mon
SCH C film I didn't really like leard
DiCaprio much in it and also W I was
kind of like I was like man I think he's
like the weakest part of this film a
weird way oh okay I mean of course dairo
is in it yeah yeah dairo is great in
Ito yeah Brendon Fraser is really
[__] weird in this film it feels like
he misunderstood the
yeah it like everyone is playing a
character and he kind of comes in
playing like a different time it was
very odd uh I love that dude whenever
he's in that Jesse plens guy yeah Tom
Tom white that's his whenever he's in a
movie it's true I've seen this on
Twitter people meme it whenever he's in
something you know it's going to be a
banger he's such a terrifying actor
whenever he's in something he's always
really scary anyway um yeah it's it's
it's a little long I also when when the
reviews came out for it I saw the
reviews and everyone was saying that the
main uh the main uh uh female lead was
was really good and I I thought I
thought she wasn't very good at all yeah
I feel bad saying that but I felt like
there was like no emotion it's just a
lot you'll see what I mean you're
sitting there and and it's just so long
and for a good period of time the same
kind of thing just keeps happening and
you're like okay I I get it I get it the
feature review is will someone tell
Marty he needs to edit his movies
down I I genuinely think right if this
was a 2hour 50-minute film it would have
been great like I think that's that's
how I felt about the Irishman as well I
was like this this could have been under
3 hours easily I know I know he loves to
do this it was a great movie but it was
too long he loves to do that thing where
he lets dialogue scenes really stretch
and I think sometimes it really works
and other times it's like hey I know
this worked in another film but I do not
care cut this down I mean it worked in
Taxi Driver so he was like I'm just
going to keep yeah I just think it was
too long I I think if I had a raided out
of 10 I'd give it like
a I feel like it's such a cop out saying
seven but I don't have any strong
feeling on either side like I cannot sit
here in good faith and say it's a bad
film but I can't sit here and be like
it's a [__]
bang that's a pure and then I watched
this [__] awful movie called five
five nights I did watch that too [__]
dog [__] movie awful movie to I don't
know any of the law of FNAF right so I
go into this film I the only thing I've
watched is like a matpat film I heard
mat in it yeah the only thing I've heard
is that he says that's just the theory
in the movie so I watched I watched it
the day came out right yeah you should
have seen my soy jacked face when I'm
sitting there and then he [__] mat
Pat turns around I was
like I was like what and then he goes
it's just a theory and I was like Ain't
No Way ain't no way they got him to say
it you know Scott coron just jacked off
to that he's like I finally made him say
it and uh the rest of the film was so
bad it was so bad it is one of the most
[__] boring films I've watched in so
long and I think the it's an hour and 50
uh yeah it's 5.5 in IMDb and I think the
only people who are rating this highly
are people who love FNAF La what's uh
what's the wrong Tomato score on this I
I want to see like the Metacritic score
dude I want to I want to see what like
the it is being and I think 29% this is
actual [__] but like viewers you
know how they they like the [__]
critics say it [__] I'm like yeah
because it is [__] look at
this 29% audience score 88% listen I'm I
am happy to clown on critics like when
they this is why the crunch Road Awards
will never work man you give an audience
a voting power and this is this is the
[__] like I I actually think I actually
think like I you know when they the when
the critics they generally had lower uh
critical reception for like films like
the Mario movie you know I felt like
that was unfair but also there was like
a mad conspiracy going actually did you
hear about this what a lot of people
were speculating that for some reason
and I think this is [__] this is
disclaim a [__] people were saying
that people were paying for bad reviews
the the that someone was uh one of the
advertising films are doing it so that
it can be like a look at the [__]
critics they don't [__] know [__]
look at us we're the fans we know what
we want you know what I mean but that's
just a theory that's just a theory but
you know there's there there's been this
giant Trend lately where people will see
a mov movie that has fan ratings High
fan ratings and low critical ratings is
like a badge of honor it's like look at
the [__] critics getting another L
don't know [__] they are so out of touch
with what the people want but this one
actually [__] [__] the viewers dude the
critics are so right this film is
actually garbage and the reason why it
has high views high ratings is because
there's fans of FNAF that are just
[__] getting hyped about it cuz a
movie's being made about FNAF and
there's loads of FNAF law that's dog
[__] and also you know favor youb are
probably in it as well yeah and a lot of
people you know a lot of the the
audience of this is targeting you know
been around for a very long time you
know they're old young adults now or
getting getting can I see what the
difference in the Mario movie
wasio mov my I think it it's gotten a
little better now but I distinctly
remember when it was out it was just
under 50% yeah see look at this
59% that's something that I can kind of
relate to because I genuinely when in
the Mario Bros movie movie and I'm like
this completely met my expectations of
everything I expected from a Mario Bros
movie it was fun it was it was it was a
fun movie would I rate it highly as a
movie if I went to do it with a critical
mind no but I was just like am I
watching this to see a Martin scy 3 and
a half hours pie of [__] Mario just
sitting around just talking with Luigi
for 15 minutes extended dialog let's
break down the character dynamic between
Mario and
listen you could give me 4 hours of Jack
Black [__] around singing and I
probably watch that I would I would just
just do that uh you know like I I to me
again this has been like a trend that I
really don't like that they're just a
lot of movies are being galvanized by
low critical reception which which makes
me wonder what were you expecting out of
out of the I I was expecting nothing I I
went into it entirely I I went into it
expecting nothing and I was like maybe
it'll be and I got well maybe maybe that
was the maybe yeah maybe I had to go in
there knowing the entire [__] law
because I saw on Twitter that people
were being like this reveal was crazy
and it turned out right this is like
this is going to show how I don't know
[__] there is two [__] Freddy fast BS
right one is brown and one is slightly
like yellow oh the golden Freddy yeah
and I'm watching this film I thought
they were the same [__] dude cuz it
looks like the same can we pull up the
difference between these two [__] if
you just type in like two Freddy's dude
as a casual viewer of the thing
uh maybe images might come up better
trying to decipher or like watching this
and like Freddy versus golden Freddy uh
yeah maybe the FNAF but I feel like in
the you got to see it in the film
version
um yeah so so in so oh okay yeah so yeah
yeah so in the movie you know he's kind
of like a brown hint and then the gold
one is kind of like a brownish gold
right it doesn't help the majority of
this and the film are in the dark yeah
and then he but I guess this character
has a blue eye but I didn't know they
were different so I'm sitting here and
it's never
explained but then I go on Twitter and
everyone's like dude this was so raw
this reveal was crazy and and then I saw
a quote retweet of someone else being
like I and I felt very very validated so
I was like I didn't even know they were
they were different cuz they just they
go if you don't know the law it's a
pretty bad movie cuz you so much of this
is like like
reveals
um and it was just [__] it was so [__]
and it was like baby's first horror
movie it was horror for kids which I I
first of all I'm a hater right I don't I
don't like this genre of horror that is
like horror for kids I'm like that takes
away what other genres I mean what the
films are in that all the new video
games that are all like kindergarten
thing but scary and it's all Baldi
Basics and yeah yeah yeah it's all this
and but this film was genuinely a horror
film for kids it was a scary film kids
hate loud noises suddenly like man this
takes away every aspect of what I think
makes horror good is that raw kind of
human uncomfortableness and now we're
just doing loud Bear yeah animatronic I
mean uh it's yeah very weird I mean
everyone was in high school once right
just yeah but I love [__] like when I
was 14 I thought Slender Man was the
goat you know and now I think back to it
I'm like that [__] ass don't [__] lie
if there was a slender there slender
there is of course this was this was dog
[__] movie and I the fact that the fans
think this is good and it's R highly is
actually a joke and makes fans look like
they don't know anything about movies
let's let's see the Slender slend was
awful slend was SL I actually watched
this one oh not not even the memes could
save it not even the mem not even the
audience 8% versus 16% audience score
god damn that is the amount of IQ points
you'll lose actually 16% that's that's
the average age actually that you need
to be to watch them I also went to the
cinema and I watched a movie called uh
hypnotic uh starring uh Ben FL oh and uh
was it good holy [__] was it
bad holy [__] the only thing I can I can
compliment this movie is that it was
short so I was out uh was it actually
short or was it short compared to the
scori film it was an hour and 40 which I
feel like is like short now nowadays
every film is [__] two and a half
hours and I hate this trend true and in
Japan it was called domino domino domino
so I'm watching this film It's called
Domino in Japan and then like the
[__] credits start goes hypnotic like
and I'm like wait is this is isn't this
Domino here like anyway so the premise
of this film is that there are these
people who exist who can just hypnotize
people on command they could be like
gone that just sounds like a HTI plot
yeah yeah it's literally like mind
literally they'll be like gone come and
then you'll just come yeah or like that
is literally like 90% of Mind break
hentai there like this scene in the film
where he's like uh I guess he's like hey
uh you should shoot yourself and then he
just shoots himself and you're like okay
I think I get this I I get it and then
there's this whole could never yeah
right and then that like the whole oh
God and they they have like these mind
battles and I [__] lost it they have
these mind battles and it's just they
just camera Zooms in on their faces and
it keeps cutting between them going like
where they're trying to like influence
each other's minds and it's just a [__]
story it it was so boring uh and there
was like a whole bunch of it's like
watching a stand fight without being it
was kind of like um now more I think
about it um what was the I think it's is
it Mar SCH no Christopher Nolan film
with the me uh dreams tion like imagine
baby's Inception like they had a kind of
similar thing where it's like but it was
all a hypnotized dream and it goes on
you're like okay I guess that's fine um
yeah this looks [__] yeah this is what
happens when a less talented director
tries to make a chrisopher Nolan film as
that's literally yeah that's that's my
feeling it literally felt like if you
had taken uh Inception and you were like
how do I make this dumber and less cool
yeah uh and Ben Affleck in the film I
thought was I swear Ben Affleck
sometimes just doesn't act he sometimes
just doesn't I feel like he just
sometimes just turns up he's like I'll
do it I think sometimes he's not even
aware he's being filmed but he's
actually like decent actor I feel like
Ben affle can be good when he wants to
be but sometimes he just shows up and he
knows the movie is not going to do well
so he just kind of was like yeah fast as
it yeah yeah it's whatever for sure um
so it was a very I left the film feeling
like [__] I kind of wish I didn't watch
it but also I like watching those films
I like having [__] to say about [__]
films um don't watch it uh is my
recommendation yeah it it really makes
hour and a half look like a Tik Tok you
know like compared to like the [__] 3
hours 40 of the schy film oh my God yeah
that was too long yeah I also had a bad
seed as well so I was kind of like this
all time [__] I was literally that that
Meme of Willam
defo uh yeah oh my God damn I mean uh
yeah uh speaking of stuff that we've
kind of done and watched recently uh
finally finished my first Final Fantasy
game oh which one yeah uh 16 I oh yeah
remember when I was just like I yeah I
gave up uh I don't know if I need to
finish this and then I was like you know
what I should finish a final fantasy
game how you feel how was it can confirm
I was like I don't think I needed to
finish it oh no yeah the ending was all
right it's it was just like everything
that I thought was going to happen
happened and I was just playing it to
literally like see the climax and the
characters like closed off and I was
like eh I think I think we can agree
though right that gav is the best
character G gab is [__] goated he
sounds like all right mate I do it no no
no that's s s is all he's also goated
but like by the end gav is goated like
he's one of those characters at first
you're just like I don't really care
about you he's like all right m i was it
going how's he going you going off for
adventure cool I mean like the F yeah
with 16 the fights were like
cinematically incredible like they
looked absolutely gorgeous but just just
the some of the charact like Jill was
the most boring [__] character I've
ever seen in a Final Fantasy game she
was so boring I think my favorite
experience with Final Fantasy which has
nothing to do with Final Fantasy but
just just like just picture it I'm just
going to say everything with the same
amount of context that I got I'm just
playing Final Fantasy we've literally
just finished talking about Final
Fantasy on a trash tase recording uh and
I'm just like ah let's just play a
little bit more get a line message from
Joey and all I see is just out of cont
text oh he gay
gay and I just I just
B I just bur out okay so there's there's
a scene one of the characters uh he's
like the the king of one of the the oh
he's like the prince of one of the
kingdoms uh that you you he's like one
of the boss fights basically um and you
know very Progressive of Square Enix uh
he he's he's a gay character right and
but it the way that they reveal that he
is a gay character just comes so
suddenly where like you're kind of
watching him talk and you're like all
right yeah he's you know just like a
typical blond haad blueeyed prpal Final
Fantasy typical Final Fantasy like
Prince character and then he just starts
making out with his God and I'm just
like whoa he and I just texted G in all
caps oh he gay gay no I I got what he
was cuz I remember playing it with
Sydney uh like the like the first like
beginning bit and and Sydney was like
he's definitely gay and I was like
Sydney we we're like this is the first I
was like no he gay and then like then
afterwards like I get the message from
Joey being like oh he gay G
so so they they they obviously like they
they did the energy well you know to be
like oh is it something they're going to
like kind of like tease is it going to
be the usual anime thing where it's just
like you know are they best friends or
are they like they is he European or is
he gay we'll never know they they
they've went full oh he gay gay does he
know yeah
I think 16 was just in the grandest
scheme of all the Final Fantasy games I
thought it was all right it epitomizes
every reason why I don't I very rarely
finish AJ RPG where it's just you have
this the ending is
important yeah but the ending is
normally some of his Parts you know it's
probably I mean it didn't do anything
that surprised me and a lot of the
interesting and more climactic uh kind
of like interesting moments for for me
uh came about 2/3 or like the last
quarter of the way through the story
where I I'm not going to spoil what my
favorite parts of this game was but
there is a climactic moment and a
climactic boss battle and that I I
remember experiencing that and I was
like this is where the game has peaked
like in my mind I was like I can't see a
moment that has that will eclipse the
moment that this has just presented me
and I was just like after that I was
kind of like I kind of just feel like
I'm just taking off the boxes now are
you are you talking about the Bahamut
Fight yes yeah that is easily the best
part of that game yeah not not just the
fight itself but just the the leadup to
that fight the moment the the moment the
payoff with all the characters as well I
was just like all right yeah there's
like this I I agree with that that was
definitely the peak of that game I was
like this is this is this is [__]
Peak and then I was just like everything
else just feels like I'm just ticking
off the boxes to make sure or they close
it off and then it continue for another
20 hours you know and just kind of
fizzle out so yeah that was
unfortunate oh there's more oh [__] all
right there was also a scene on the
beach where I was just
like I agree that was also Peak what is
the scene it's the scene basically where
spoilers for six scene it's basically
the scene where Clive our main character
and Jill the main love interest they
finally kissed
right um and but to give context they're
naked on this beach for about a full
five minutes and I'm just like cuz they
just are I can't remember the context
but I remember them being naked and like
J talking about her [__] motivations
and being like a good like I I'll be
with you to the yank live and I'm just
like just [__] do it already just
[__] [__] right now just do it just do
it just stop [__] teasing me c is
there just sitting there listening
ricked up the [__] it's just like can
you shut up I really want to make out
with you right now yeah I remember when
it finally happened I like threw my
controller I was just like oh finally oh
it happened oh my than God yeah it
didn't make the ending any better though
but yeah yeah it was it I I thought it
was a an all right Final Fantasy game
when you played uh six no eight eight
did you like did you have that same
feeling where you just like about like
the last third you're like okay I'm just
like Tak off the boxes now I think has a
more interesting yeah I actually really
like the ending to eight really I
thought it was a already cool ending uh
that that it was almost in the Middle
where it kind of lost me actually the
start really the start was often I find
yeah the start of long jrpgs are the
hardest to get into cuz like you you if
you're a JG person you're so willing to
jump into that yeah but if you're not I
feel like that is the first 20 hours is
where you're just that's crazy to say
the first 20 hours but like that's where
you're going to lose a lot of people cuz
it's like that you have to really give
this world a lot of like hope that it's
going to pay off you think that's a
valid
argument for just any piece of media it
gets good after no [__] no X hours no
bro
JoJo scy has a 4-Hour film and we're
discussing whether that's too long so to
go to someone and be like hey you know
it gets good 20 hours in that's
psychotic to say that it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be like
that GE would be like
Jojo I think JoJo Just yeah JoJo's kind
of it's a tough one it's really tough
and I think Jo you know I know you don't
want to true just kind of the first part
is the weakest and that's what makes it
by far the hardest to get into totally
um which is a shame it is the jrpg of
anime it kind of is and it's really bad
because it's like it's also hasn't quite
found its like I feel like it's kind of
charm in season one yet it's still
trying to figure out how dumb to go with
it oh totally no cuz I was I was
thinking about this cuz I was uh like
looking for another game to get into uh
and I was like Starfield I think maybe
seems kind of up my alley it's like
sci-fi and I was looking up like reviews
and stuff and people like there was like
quite a few articles that were like you
know the first 12 hours were pretty like
mediocre but then it gets good that's
that's Fu and I'm
like huh yeah huh that's a not from me
dog yeah that's that's that's a that's a
big that's a full-time job to start
appreciating something I'm I'm like in
two minds about this right cuz I I I do
think that you know there is an argument
to be made that it gets good after X
hours um is like a valid argument
because there there's like a certain
argument where there are some stories
like for example one piece where the
scale is so [__] Grand that I think
the like I think the it takes this many
manga chapters or this many volumes um
to get into like the world of one piece
I I like I honestly think that is
Justified just with the scale of the
story being told in one piece and then
there is other things where I think it's
kind of like a Stockholm syndrome where
you're in this game or you're in this
like story for so long that you're like
yeah I think it's good but that's
because I spent this many hours playing
it would you would you say then the that
like say JoJo fits into the one piece
side of the mold or the other side cuz
it's kind of in the middle in my opinion
it's a bit of both it's like yeah it's a
very grandio Story I mean it's been
going longer than one piece technically
speaking Yeah but it's also like it's
not it's also not as consistent as one
pieces as well so it's like it's hard to
say cuz you know a lot of people will
say like oh yeah yeah just you know just
don't worry after season after part one
it'll it'll get it part two is good part
two is good you know what it's hard to
get people into you know what you know
what I think it's the Stockholm syndrome
I I I'm I'm thinking about it and I'm
thinking why okay fans don't want to
admit it I I I didn't even want to say
like part one or whatever I was thinking
like part three part three yeah where
the reason I liked part three was just
because I love the feeling of like just
going on a trip with the boys right and
I just I just remember thinking man this
was really dragged out yeah I think part
three was worse than part one yeah but
holy [__] like did I did I value my time
with the boys just because I was forced
to sit down and see the entire
because you knew that if you got through
that then part four and five would be
next which are just goed yeah so it's
like I'll just stick through it cuz I
know I'm going to get to the good stuff
I don't think I would have I just
happened to have it I happened to be
able to watch it I had no internet and I
think that's the only reason I watched
it is cuz I just happened to I was the
only I could watch and because season 3
was so long and I don't think I could go
back and rewatch it I I just go back and
rewatch the last five episodes I'm like
yeah this is good yeah yeah but uh yeah
I think it's definitely very very tough
to get into it for Jojo fans Sor sorry
JoJo fans I do love it though obviously
but it is just so hard to get people to
watch it yeah it's it's definitely hard
to justify not that you should have to
justify getting everyone into a certain
show if you don't like Jojo that's fine
but uh hey that's our opinions on anime
there's your anime episode this is this
is the ending to this ending episode of
uh trash taste did this ending stick
yeah did we stick The Landing for this
ending hey let us know your thoughts and
opinions on anything we said especially
the attack on titans St if there's any
like obvious endings iconic that we
missed off please tell me let us know
yeah like I I think like I would love to
know what your iconic manga ending is
cuz I don't know why it almost feels
like with manga endings I've stuck with
it for so long that the ending just
doesn't matter to me and yeah yeah too I
mean I would say punp as an amazing
ending but I'm also biased on that so
but it is it is an amazing ending but
hey let us know your thoughts and
opinions down in the comments also check
out these patrons o see they they stick
around to the ending they stick around
to the ending of every episode and you
can do the same by going over to our
patreon at patreon.com trashtaste also
follow us on Twitter send us memes on
the subr and if you hate our face listen
to us on Spotify and we will see you
guys in a probably non-anime related
episode next all right guys
bye
[Music]